[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله شاهدتم بعد ابرز
فيديوهات الاسبوع الماضي ولكن ماذا عن
اخباره لنتابعها سويه من هنا من غرفه
اخبار الجزيره معي انا محمد مزيمس اهلا
بكم
البدايه مع خبر الاتفاق السعودي الايراني
الذي ياتي بعد سنوات من القطيعه حيث اتفق
البلدان على استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
واعاده فتح السفارتين والممثلات
الدبلوماسيه وتفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون
الامني بينهما واحترام لسياده الدول وذلك
عاقبه مبحثات في الصين ورغبه من البلدين
في حل الخلافات بالحوار والدبلوماسيه بحسب
ما ذكرت وكاله الانباء السعوديه الاتفاق
لاقي ترحيبا عربيا وقلقا اسرائيليا في حين
نقلت واشنطن انه ليس واضحا ما اذا كان
سيؤثر على اتفاقيات ابرحا لنتصل بمراسلنا
نور الدين الضغير في طهران
مرحبا نور الدين ماذا بعد هذه الخطوه
محمد هي خطوه مهمه اتخذتها كل من ايران
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه من اجل اعاده
تطوير العلاقات بينهما لكن الاهم في كل
هذا هو انتظار ما ستسفر عنه اللقاءات ما
بين وزير خارجيه ايران والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي التي ستحدد خطوط هذه العوده
بافتتاح السفرات والقنصليات والكل كذلك
ينتظر مدى تاثير هذه العوده على مجموعه من
ملفات الاشتباك ما بين الرياض وطهران خاصه
ملف الازمه اليمنيه وامكانيه حلها بهذه
العوده للعلاقات ما بين البلدين بالاضافه
الى ملف الرئاسه في لبنان وملفات اقليميه
اخرى في العراق وفي سوريا بكل تاكيد الكل
ينتظر ما ستسفر عنه هذه العوده للعلاقات
ما بين طهران والرياض شكرا نور الدين
يعطيك الف عافيه الان الى شان الفلسطيني
عمليه في شارع ريزنكوب وسط تل ابيب ادت
الى اصابه خمسه اسرائيليين واستشهاد
منفذها الشاب المعتز بالله الخواجه حماس
تبنت العمليه وقالت انها رد على جرائم
الاحتلال وتوعدت بالمزيد بينما امر
الاحتلال بهدم منزل المنفذ واعتقل افرادا
من اسرته هذه العمليه جاءت في ظل تصعيد
عسكري اسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
واقتحامات ادت الى استشهاد عدد من
الفلسطينيين هناك محاوله لخفض التوتر خلال
شهر رمضان المبارك في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وكنا قد سالناكم عن رايكم ان كانت حده
التصعيد سترتفع ام لا وذلك على صفحتنا على
تويتر وهكذا كانت اجابتكم واحد وثمانون
فاصله سته في المئه قالوا نعم ستستمر
بينما قال
18.4% منكم وذلك حتى تسجيل هذه الحلقه من
انجازنا الاسبوعي ماساه جديده تصيب
الروهينغا اذ اندلع حريق ضخم في مخيم
للاجئين بمدينه كوكس بازار في بنغلاديش
حيث التهمت النيران اعدادا كبيره من الخيم
والاكواخ التي يقطنونها وهو ما اجبر الالف
منهم على ترك منازلهم بينما اعلنت تسلطات
هو في بنغلاديش فتحه تحقيق في اسباب
الحريق وقد اطلقت الامم المتحده نداء لجمع
تمويل فوري لتلبيه احتياجاتهم الانسانيه
في التعليق الاول تجدون مقطع فيديو يذكر
بوضع مسلميه روهينيا
وبماساتهم المستمره من بنجلاديش الى فرنسا
وجدلي تعديل قانون التقاعد حيث تشهد المدن
الفرنسيه مظاهرات واضرابات رفضا لرفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 وقد شارك فيها
اكثر من مليون شخص وتسببت بشلل في قطاع
النقل العام والغاء الع رحلات الجويه
واغلاق بعض المدارس اضافه الى تكدس هي
النفايات وتوقف شاحنات الوقود روادو منصات
التواصل للعرب تفاعلوا مع مشاهد اشتباكات
قوات الامن الفرنسيه
والمتظاهرين لنقرا بعض التغريدات عباس
اسكندر قلم متهكما نطالب المجتمع الدولي
التدخل لحمايه المواطنين من بطش النظام
الفرنسي فرنسا تعذب مواطنيها على حد ما
قال اما رحموني عبد الغني فقال هكذا
تتعامل فرنسا مع شعبها قررت النقابات
الفرنسيه البارحه التظاهره ضد قانون
التقاعد حقوق الانسان كذبه الغرب الكبرى
مثل ما قال ايضا رحموني عبد الغني في ظل
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تعاني منها البلاد
الحكومه المصريه تصدر قرارا يتضمن تسهيلات
لمنح الجنسيه للمستثمرين الاجانب وذلك
مقابل شراء المنشات والاستثمار في الشركات
او ايداعي مبال عمليه بالدولار وذلك سعيا
لجذب المزيد من العمله الصعبه كما تضمنت
التسهيلات الجديده تخفيض قيمتي المبلغ
المطلوب لشراء عقار مقابل الجنسيه من 500
الف دولار الى 300 الف نختم بالرياضه
والخروج المبكر لباريس سان جيرمان من دوري
ابطال اوروبا بعد ان قضى بايرن ميونخ على
امال الفريق الباريسي في دوري 16 من
البطوله وفاز عليه بثلاثيه نظيفه في مجموع
مبارتي الذهاب والعوده هذا الخروج اثار
السياقه واستغراب البعض لاذهب الان الى
زميل عمار نامق مدير النشرات الرياضيه
معنا هنا في الجزيره مرحبا عمار مرحبا
كيف يمكن لفريق يضم كل هؤلاء اللاعبين
المعروفين واغلى اللاعبين
ويخسر من هذا الدور دور لان بكل امانه
محمد يعني هذه المباراه مباراه باريس سان
جيرمان مع بايرن ميونخ اثبتت ان كره القدم
هي لعبه جماعيه لا تعترف بالاسماء لا
تعترف بالنجوم لا تعترف باي شيء بكثر ما
من سيعطيها في الملعب على ارض الواقع وهذا
كان دليل ليس بذلك الفريق الذي لا يمتلك
نجوم او اسماء لكن زياده باريس سان جيرمان
وعديد الاسماء الموجوده في هذا الفريق
تجعل انه هذا الفريق هو الاول في العالم
لكن ما النتيجه محمد ما كانت النتيجه
خساره في مباراه الذهب في باريس وخساره
ايضا في ميونخ في مباراه الاياب وبالتالي
الوداع المبكر لذلك كره القدم هي لعبه
جماعيه الاسماء مهمه النجوم مهمين جدا لكن
التوليفه التوليفه الصحيحه لكل هؤلاء
واصلا هي تعرف على انها لعبه جماعيه مثل
ما ذكرت فالاصل هو الذي يعمل النجاح فريق
على حساب اخر بكل تاكيد محمد شكرا جزيلا
لك عمار نامق شكرا لكم انتم ايضا على
متابعتي انجازنا الاسبوعين نلتقي بحول
الله الاسبوع المقبل اينما كنت م قبل
توقعتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]